[Music]
among the reasons that I heard for
people wanting to vote for brexit were
well it's nice to have a change and well
I preferred the old blue Passport to the
European purple Passport these are the
kinds of reasons people were giving for
voting for brexit
the day after the referendum the most
googled question in Britain was what is
the European Union during the brexit
campaign one of the leading politicians
favouring brexit Michael Gove said to
the British people you are the experts
you don't trust experts you are the
experts now so ordinary people who have
absolutely no no knowledge of economics
or politics or history decided on a 50%
majority to vote Britain out of the
European market which was a out of the
European community which was a very very
complicated detailed ramified structure
that had been built up over decades and
so at one stroke the the British people
who had no knowledge no expertise were
allowed well given the opportunity by a
reckless David Cameron to vote us out
and they did by a very narrow margin
this count of everybody being an expert
all opinions being equally valid is I
think dangerous and most unfortunate of
course I have been accused of being an
elitist because of this and yes I mean
when you're about to have an operation
you want an elite surgeon to do the to
cut you open you want an elite
anesthetist to put you under when you're
about to fly what an elite pilot to fly
you when you're about to leave a
Federation of states which has been
built up over decades you want an elite
economist or politician or historian to
advise you on it you don't want to take
the the view of just any old man in the
street a woman in the street
I have pronounced myself profoundly
ill-equipped to vote on the referendum
about brexit I was ill-equipped so were
the vast majority of the British people
I look ill-equipped in that sense I
think that elitist should stop being a
dirty word and we should start to
respect elites in whatever field we're
talking about we want elite musicians to
play in our orchestras etc I think it's
bad enough to ask non experts like me to
vote and direct referendums whenever
when we are also being fed false
information moriss deliberately false
information I mean in the the Trump
administration is actually lying every
day and more or less proud of it
in Britain the brexit campaign had a bus
you may read about this they had a bus
which had a great big slogan on that on
the side which said that every day every
week I think it was some gigantic Sun
was being paid to the into the European
Union which would be if we left the if
we left Europe would be available for
the National Health now that was a
admitted lie that was simply quite
simply false and many people were
probably swayed by that consideration to
vote to leave the European Union so no I
do I do think we need to stick to
democracy as it is but I think it's a
representative democracy that we have in
Britain we have a parliamentary
democracy where we don't actually vote
normally we don't vote on actual issues
we vote members of parliament members of
parliament then go to the House of
Commons and then they vote on our behalf
and we have cabinet government where the
cabinet gets advice from civil servants
who are expert so no I'm not advocating
that a you know people with PhDs should
get to vote so in anything light like
that I mean I don't want it to be
elitist to quite that extent so let's go
for representative democracy but not
referendum democracy and I think it's
worth adding that the the precedent for
not everybody having the same vote same
weighted vote is already
well-established in the United States
when you think about voting for the
United States Senate where every state
gets two senators what that means is
that a citizen of Wyoming has I think
equivalent of sixty votes compared to a
citizen of California because if you
look at the actual relative population
sizes of Wyoming and California so in a
way that pass has already been sold that
we already see gross inequality 760 fold
inequalities in the in the weight and
the Senate of course is very important
because the Senate does not only take
hugely important decisions but also
ratifies presidential nominees for the
Supreme Court and that could be the most
important single thing that a president
ever does is appoint members to the
Supreme Court because they go on and on
for decades in say in some cases after
the president has gone
[Music]